بدأ كل شيء بتوقيع النجم
كريستيانو رونالدو
بعقد لمدة عامين ونصف قدرت وسائل الإعلام
قيمته بأكثر من 220 مليون دولار
لمهاجم ريال مدريد السابق كريم
بنزيمو جوردان
هندرسون،
المدير الفني السابق لأستون فيلا ستيفن
جيرارد ونيمار لاعب باريس سان جيرمان.
إنشاء دوري سوبر ستار لكرة
القدم خاص بها مع خطط لتعطيل
صناعة كرة القدم العالمية. أعتقد
أن السعوديين قد نبهوا الجميع إلى
أنك تعرف القيم
التي تم الإبلاغ عنها أم
هل تعرف خمسة إلى ستة أضعاف
الرواتب التي يتقاضونها  يتم عرضها في
أوروبا، ومن المؤكد أن أي رياضي
يُعرض عليه ذلك مرة أخرى لديه
مسيرة مهنية قصيرة في كرة القدم، يجب عليه
بالتأكيد أن يأخذ في الاعتبار ذلك لأنه
سيتعين عليه إعالة نفسه على
تلك الأموال لبقية حياته.
ويقول منتقدو السعودية إن المملكة قد
تسعى إلى تحسين سمعتها من خلال
هذه الصفقات رفيعة المستوى وصرف الانتباه
عن سجلها في مجال حقوق الإنسان، لكن الرجل الذي
يقف وراء الدوري السعودي للمحترفين كالانورا
يقول إن البلاد يجب أن تدافع عن مصالحها الخاصة،
ولكل شخص الحق في إبداء رأيه الخاص
، لدينا خطة  لدينا استراتيجية،
إنها نهج طويل المدى، وهذا ليس مجرد ومضة
عابرة وسنختفي في
العام المقبل، لقد فتحنا للتو
قناة جديدة للاعبين لم تكن موجودة
ولماذا يمكن ذلك  لا يكون في الشرق
الأوسط، لماذا لا يكون في المملكة العربية السعودية،
لماذا يجب أن يكون حصريًا في
أوروبا، نحن نتحدى الوضع الراهن،
ما الذي نفعله، نحن نفعل شيئًا
من أجل المملكة العربية السعودية، نحن نفعل شيئًا من
أجل  السكان المحليين وهذا
شيء يجب على أي شخص آخر أن يشعر
بالارتياح تجاه ما تقوله لتلك
الحجة القائلة بأنهم
يأتون إلى هنا للحصول على المال في
الوقت الحالي،
كل ما يمكننا فعله هو وضع المنتج
قدر الإمكان  أرى أنه ليس لاعبًا واحدًا، بل
عدة لاعبين، وليس ناديًا واحدًا، بل
أندية متعددة، فهو يرفع
المد الذي سيرفع مستوى All
Ships ولكن
لا يكفي بالنسبة لي أن أخبركم
بهذه الأشياء، سيستغرق الأمر بعض
الوقت حتى يتمكن الجميع من ذلك  كن مقتنعًا بأن
هذا هو المكان الذي نريد أن نذهب إليه وقد
مرت الدوريات الأخرى بنفس الشيء الذي
تعرفه يتبادر إلى ذهنك الدوري الأمريكي لكرة القدم، لقد
استغرق الأمر سنوات عديدة
وتطوروا بمرور الوقت وستكون هذه هي
الرحلة نفسها تمامًا بالنسبة لنا ما هي
الإستراتيجية  لماذا تفعل ما
تفعله؟ تم
منح SPL أهدافًا مختلفة منذ بضع
سنوات لتحسين الأداء على أرض الملعب
مع لاعبين من الطراز العالمي
المشاركين لزيادة عدد
الحضور ولدفع
تسويق
الدوري من خلال الأصول التي
نتحكم فيها  والجمع بين كل هؤلاء الثلاثة
ثم الارتقاء بأنفسنا في
سلم الدوري لنصبح واحدًا من
أفضل خمس بطولات دوري محترمة في العالم
وما رأيناه مع
عامل رونالدو هو الحضور القياسي في
موسم 22-23 الذي مر للتو.  لقد رأيت
اهتمامًا في جميع أنحاء العالم
من خلال حقوق البث الخاصة بنا، الأمر
الواضح هو أن الاهتمام
يتزايد يومًا بعد يوم، لذا أخبرني عن
أهدافك من حيث
المساهمة الاقتصادية ومساهمة الناتج المحلي الإجمالي،
فنحن نرتكز على
رؤية  الدولة بأكملها
وحيث تريد Vision 30 أن تأخذ المملكة العربية
السعودية، لذلك
نشعر أن الالتزام
بمواصلة قيادة ودعم
الدوري أمر
ضروري لمستقبلنا ولكن
يجب أن أقول أيضًا أن
كرة القدم هذه يجب أن تكون مساهمًا صافيًا في
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي، لا ينبغي لنا ذلك  أن نجلس هنا ونتحدث
عن التكلفة التي ينبغي أن تكلفها البلاد،
بل عن مقدار
مساهمتنا في قطع أراضي البلاد،
ما مدى ثقتك في قدرتك على تحقيق
ذلك، إنه ليس خيارًا علينا،
فنحن مشغولون بتطوير صناعة ما  هنا
ما لا يمكننا فعله هو الاستمرار في استيراد
المواهب لإدارة الصناعة بالنسبة لنا،
فهناك أكثر من المواهب القادرة في
المملكة العربية السعودية
التي يمكن إعدادها لتولي
زمام الأمور ومواصلة البناء على
الأسس التي وضعناها لهم
[موسيقى]